hi i'm vishy anand
and what i'm going to do now is to try
out these
new bots on chess.com
i'm probably going to try out anish
i'll have to do myself and uh
maybe one more thing but let you know
let's let's just give it a twirl and see
how much fun it is
uh incidentally there's a lot of them
you can do
that you can do bloody so have fun
okay so um
let's play against some bots
i don't know where to start but let's
start with anishikiri
and i think that is now the option
so
[Music]
yeah no help and let's just see how that
goes
okay before
okay let's do that
okay this is uh quite a sharp line
um let's
okay that is kind of unusual for me
because i expect
okay he's gonna go for all the pawns is
he
okay let's get the king out of the way
and then prop that up there
okay knight beat three
oh did i miss something
ah clever
have i been
that is annoying
let's take that and hope for the best
it should still be good for me but you
don't feel quite the same way
two pawns down against a computer as you
do with
human beings but i've still got a good
lead in development so
let's see where this goes okay
i think the check is gonna be
i'm gonna be quite happy to get a check
in nope he's not gonna allow me
okay let's put the rook in there
[Music]
should i play bishop c7 should i go to
c1
[Music]
i don't know where to go
[Music]
group d1 what would
he goes e6
okay let's try that
okay i think uh yes that works so
check and take
these and luckily i've got my knight f1
so i should be okay over there
in fact let me just go ahead and do that
and then i can put the bishop
there which should slow him down a bit
okay so everybody is happy
i can go to case seven
[Music]
and i and if i go queen c7 then
things are coming along rather nicely
so bishop c5 collect the pawn and okay
now it's winning so this is
that was fun it's funny a position i
would
take very happily against any human
being against the computer you still
have to see
whether you're missing a pawn here or
upon there
uh but now i'm a piece up so
all good let's go hitch
you know what let's exchange the roots
i'd rather not have to calculate
anything
yeah and now i'll come back the queen
and bishop
cling to each other oh he's gonna go for
that
so let me
swap the ships
and he's going to go h4 h3 if i go
bishop c3 he goes
h4 bishop takes f6 annoying he can't do
that so
let's get rid of the bishops
okay funny boy
oh this is very nice it's simplifying to
an endgame which
is what i want to do
[Music]
let's do a little razzle dazzle
and then do that pick up the g4 pawn
okay
it's hard to believe that i'm going to
have technical difficulties here but
i'm pretty sure i will
anyway um
should i go g4 should i open tonight
let's go here just see what he wants to
do
okay let me come back
ah that was incredibly sweet of him
and i think i can step around
it's quite strange that he's uh
simplifying into like okay it's a bottle
so let let's not go over the top here
with a lot of analysis
okay eventually
initial resign
let's get that on one step let's get it
another step
let's get it one more step and the king
is gonna run back so this should be
easy peasy
okay that's fun
so
you didn't want to under promote no
apparently not
i must say one of the nice things about
playing these bots is all the witty
sentences that have been
programmed in so
of course some of them get repeats
fine